up front it looks like another barber
shop but in the back there's a party
kind of like a mullet only classier
we're talking about the barbershop cuts
and Cocktails and joining us today is
their lead mixologist Tony arnoni thank
you for being here thank you for having
me this is a great concept it is a
barbershop a functioning Barber Shop yes
the front of the barbershop is a fully
functioning barber shop with amazing
Barbers and then you go through a secret
entrance I won't spoil the surprise for
you okay but in the back there is
whiskey and rock and roll you wouldn't
know it then walking into to the barber
shop no clue you have to know that
that's better is there that's the beauty
of it that's great then when is it open
where is it and how can people find it
so it's going to be on the first floor
of the cosmo okay we have live rock and
roll seven days a week okay so today I'm
gonna run you through some of the
cocktails okay inside the barbershop and
popular this time of year I'm assuming
very very popular this time of year all
right what do you got for us today so A
beautiful concept that we came up with
at the barber shop is something I like
to call shareable Cocktails which is
very very good for New Year's Eve
bringing people together okay so this is
the bunny and Clyde cocktail it is going
to be a flash that you actually get to
keep oh that's nice yeah yeah so this
concept I came up with it's kind of a
good balance between sweets and shrunk
for any palette okay okay it's called
what again the Bonnie and Bonnie and
Clyde okay all right let's rest so let's
dive into this okay
all right so first we're gonna just ice
the glass here how long has this been
open now so the barber shop has been
open on we're going on our fourth year
all right
literally the best kept secret in Las
Vegas first floor of the Cosmopolitan
does it say Barbershop cuts and
Cocktails or just barber shops it says
Barbershop cuts and cups okay so you
know that's right that's the right place
you'd what ask for the secret door or
something
we'll have to go
all right so what are we pouring in
first so this is the Bunning Clyde it is
going to be a ritten house 100 which is
a very strong Rye based whiskey
Cointreau which is a French orange
liqueur aperol which is a aperitif lemon
juice and sugar so it's a nice balance
of sweet and strong really good for any
palette has that nice strong balanced
flavor okay
and so you pre-prepared this right this
is already in the flask yes and you
actually get to keep the flask like I
said it is a shareable cocktail so it
does serve two people they're awesome
yeah what do this run can I ask of
course you can so it runs 38 okay and
you get to keep the flash which on the
strip I gotta say is a bargain because I
you know it's crazy especially for the
flavors yeah yes fantastic with this
nice orange it is a beautiful drink
thank you smells good as well
very nice thank you very nice what else
should people be asking for so as you
know like I said we have live rock and
roll music starting next Thursday we
have bands such as The Regulators the
442s and then on Sunday we have the wild
wolves
fantastic Tony thanks so much for being
here and telling us all about the
barbershop at the Cosmopolitan first
floor go in and then say some secret
word do a dance I don't know what it is
but you'll find the Speakeasy in the
back of the place Jillian